une nuit comme la baronne de Rothschild
en plein cœur de la Vallée de Chevreuse
pour le calendrier 100 % evvelinois je
vous propose de plonger en plein cœur
d'un lieu chargé d'histoire le temps
d'une nuit l'abaye des vaau
[Musique]
cermé fondé en 1118 par des moines
l'abaye prend son essort en devenant
abbaye cisterciienne en 1147 elle tombe
dans l'oubli au 18e siècle mais elle
prend son essort un siècle plus tard
grâce à une personne la baronne de
rothchid et elle passonnera le domaine
tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui
transformé en hôtel 5 étoiles par Paris
Society le domaine regroupe une centaine
de chambres vous pourrez dormir dans
l'une des prestigieuses chambres
prestigieuses dans l'ancienne écurie
baptisé le hara ou au Pavillon du
domaine compte à partir de 250 € la nuit
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut y faire à
part dormir profiter de la nature lors
d'un tour de barque sur le lac vous
détendre au spa ou au cinéma de quoi
garantir une escapade féérique aux
portes de
Paris